wild hearts's Inspirations are obvious
but its unique high-speed crafting
system creates a novel way to ground and
defeat gigantic beasts the easy line to
draw from Wild Hearts the upcoming
hunting game from Publishers EA and koi
Tecmo and developer Omega Force is
capcom's Monster Hunter wild Hearts is a
game about exploring large open areas
alone or with two other players to take
down gigantic monsters that move around
the map as you fight them
and the developers don't entirely shy
away from that comparison but they're
aspiring to do something much more than
just replicate Monster Hunter the games
share many similarities but developer
Omega Force has explored the genre
before with a few games in the toucaden
series in those games like in Monster
Hunter and in Wild Hearts you hunt giant
monsters to harvest them for material
which can be used to upgrade your
equipment despite their lineage in the
genre koi Tecmo is quick to say that
wild Hearts is not an extension of the
toucan World they said quote
unfortunately there is no overlap this
is a completely new IP for us we know
that some of our fans were hoping it
would have some overlap with tukaden but
it doesn't wild hearts and tukuden
unfortunately exist in two separate
universes but wild Hearts has allowed
Omega Force to pick up where it left off
in the genre in a big well-funded way
all while exploring an impressive
crafting system called karakuri that
makes it stand apart wild Hearts has
been in development for four years and
represents an unlikely partnership
between EA and koi Tecmo the former is
an American publisher known
predominantly for its sports games in
the latter is a Japanese publisher that
has had success with Dynasty Warriors
the historical action series wild Hearts
is being published under EA's Originals
label which has birthed successful games
like unravel and 2021's it takes two
despite EA Originals so far doing a good
job of embracing the word original and
Publishing games you wouldn't normally
expect to come from EA it is still
surprising to see the announcement of
wild hearts playing it is also
surprising in some ways and not at all
surprising in other ways we were given
access to an early build that let us
play through the opening of the first
few major combat encounters the
non-surprising part parts of the game
will be familiar to anyone who has
played a hunting game like monster
hunter in recent years movement feels
similar as does the basic combat of the
tutorials the layout of the world is
also familiar with these large and dense
distinct separated areas that can be
accessed from The Hub City and each of
those areas houses a few different
creatures all of that we've seen before
the process of failing one of these
giant creatures referred to as kimono
and wild Hearts has a Cadence I have
also experienced before but there is
plenty that gives the game a unique
identity the main one being the karakuri
system karakuri is the crafting system
and in the fiction of wild Hearts it's a
type of magic that instantly produces
impressive pieces of engineering that
you can use in fascinating ways the
first karakuri you unlock is the ability
to produce a box you can climb on top of
that ejects you into the air you can
quickly generate multiple stacked boxes
scrambled to the top and leap this is
useful for exploring the environment but
it gets really fun when you're fighting
a kimono you can stack the boxes to get
above your opponent and launch a
devastating downward attack use it to
quickly get in the air to dodge an area
of effect attack or even create a
barrier to slow down a rampage in kimono
creating these devices is fast recalling
an expert fortnite Builder and even
during my short time with the game I
unlocked a collection of interesting
ones that were helpful both inside and
outside of combat during my second
kimono encounter I unlocked what I would
best describe as a bounce pad that I
could use to both quickly fire me out of
the way of incoming attacks or shoot me
toward the kimono for added damage after
that fight I unlocked this gigantic rope
arrow that I could Mount into the ground
and shoot off into the distance to
create zip lines to make traveling
around the world fast faster and easier
later game footage also showed walls to
be used in combat devices to let you
Glide from high heights and a lot more
the other nice thing about the karakuri
is they are permanent within your world
as are the karakuri placed by other
players participating in your game which
another added bonus they're usable by
everyone for koe Tecmo crafting was an
early idea the team wanted to integrate
into wild hearts and the first versions
had you preparing the devices before
heading out into the world or finding
them along the way and picking them up
and carrying them with you through
iteration though they found it was much
more fun to make the devices quickly in
the middle of combat optimistically the
karakuri system is the mechanic that I
think will separate wild Hearts from
comparable hunting games and I was
really impressed with how quickly I was
able to integrate the devices into all
the combat scenarios
wild hearts's other major distinguishing
factor is the design of its kimono Omega
forces stated goal for its creatures is
they be a combination of animals and
nature and and by Nature they mean like
the environment the kimono that have
been shared as well as the few that I
fought had clear familiar animal Roots
but they were covered in things like
tree roots and Moss the kimono looked as
though they could curl up in the forest
and be confused for a giant overgrown
Rock which makes them all the more
intimidating when you wake them up and
they start running in your direction
during my combat with the kimono I used
a standard Katana and I also unlocked an
umbrella weapon that when used correctly
allowed me to stay up in the air for
short periods of time to float and Dodge
various attacks there are six other
weapons available in the game that will
each have their own combo systems and
finishing move animations
[Music]
when you defeat a kimono before the
battle truly ends you have this chance
to deliver one final blow with a fancy
animation doing this ends the battle and
also instantly rewards you with all the
spoils of Victory there's no need to
stand over the corpse and manually
collect your winnings koi Tecmo sees
this as a specific design choice and a
distinguishing factor of wild Hearts
they said they wanted the players who
put their lives on the line to be
instantly rewarded you know when they
succeed some other small details we
learned from our time with the game and
speaking with koi Tecmo is wild Hearts
will feature an English dub the footage
of the build you're seeing here featured
Japanese dialogue Cooperative players
will be able to drop into the middle of
fights and the main story campaign will
take about 30 hours to complete but
there will be plenty of side quests to
tackle as well as post-game content that
will extend the game even further koi
Tecmo also is promising full cross Play
support and teased some light farming
mechanics and some fishing mechanics as
well wild Hearts will feel familiar to
fans of hunting games like Monster
Hunter but I walked away impressed with
how big a swing this game is from Koi
Tecmo and EA and Omega Force it doesn't
look or particularly play like any game
the developer or Publishers normally
release outside of tukaden and I am
excited to experiment more with the
karakuri system it's the mechanic that
will help wild Hearts stand out from the
crowd and I enjoyed the process of
scrambling up a stack of boxes I built
and leaping off the top to bring down a
powerful blow on a rampage in kimono I
imagine I will be doing it a lot more
with different karakori devices on
February 17th of next year when it
releases for PlayStation 5 Xbox series X
and PC